the overwhelming majority of prehensile
tails in nature are round but seahorse
tails are square so what does having a
square tail do for the seahorse to find
out
researchers printed a 3d model of a
segment of the seahorses square tail
structure complete with vertebrae and
outer skeleton and they pitted it
against a model of a hypothetical round
tail hypothetical since round seahorse
tails don't exist in nature they hit the
models with a mallet simulating the
crushing jaws of a water bird the square
tail came out the clear winner its
smoothly overlapping joints made it
strong and resilient absorbing more
energy upon impact than the circular
tail the researchers also simulated the
seahorses prehensile grasp the square
model maintained a better grip because
it shared more surface area with the
object it was holding on to future
seahorse inspired inventions could
include a flexible robotic arm for
performing surgery rescue and
exploration robots that fit into tight
spaces and flexible lightweight body
armor with or without a tail
you